wir regen uns richtig auf es geht um 2 g
es geht um das thema 2 g.de 2g bedeutet
ja in ein restaurant beispielsweise oder
in ein theater ein kino dürfen nur
corona genesene oder gegen korona
geimpfte person in berlin möchte jetzt
als ein weiteres bundesland diese zweig
regel einführen achtung diese zweig
regel sollen die würze beispielsweise
oder theater kinobetreiber selbst
umsetzen können bedeutet aber dass
kinder über zwölf die nicht geimpft sind
nicht rein dürfen bisher ist es ja so
dass man einfach sagt kinder werden
regelmäßig getestet in der schule
deswegen sind sie haben sie quasi ein
freifahrtschein nein berlin versucht
hier als kinderfeindlich das bundesland
genau dieses nicht zu tun und warum es
berlin so kinderfeindlich wir haben das
auch erlebt beim thema schule lockdown
zwei schulyok downs gab's im frühjahr
2020 und natürlich den großen lockdown
von dezember 2020 bis früher fast sommer
muss man sagen 20 21 und berlin war
jeweils immer das bundesland was die
schulen als letztes geöffnet hat es gab
sogar eine aussage der berliner
schulsenatorin die im letzten jahr sagte
drei wochen vor den sommerferien es
würde sich ja gar nicht mehr lohnen die
schulen zu öffnen und dieses jahr sagte
sie bereits sechs wochen vor den
sommerferien auch es würde keine schule
oft noch mal geben und nur ein gericht
hat am ende die schulsenatorin oder
berlin dazu gezwungen die schule
überhaupt wieder zu öffnen also berlin
kinderfreundlichste stadt deutschlands
man kann auch sagen verantwortlich dafür
ist der ministerpräsident hier der
regierende bürgermeister michael müller
er ist damit der kinderkiste
ministerpräsident dieses landes wir
müssen einmal schauen wie er reagiert
ich finde es wirklich unfassbar man muss
das einmal noch mal eine ordnen zweig
bedeutet wenn soll genesen sein oder hat
man so eine impfung erhalten haben die
impfung können kinder unter zwölf jahren
nicht erhalten man könnte ausnahmen
machen wie beispielsweise hamburg und
das hat man auch nachgefragt bei michael
müller dem regierenden bürgermeister
hier in berlin und wir schauen uns mal
seine reaktion darauf an hier auf
twitter noch einmal zur klarstellung
heißt es dein hamburg dem ersten
bundesland des 2g eingeführt hat gibt es
eine ausnahmeregel nach der kinder unter
zwölf jahren generell zweig angebote
nutzen dürfen die gibt es in berlin
nicht fragezeichen fragezeichen das ist
wirklich unfassbar die antwort ist in
berlin gibt es diese maßnahme nicht dies
wurde
der konferenz erläuterte ohne jegliches
verständnis ohne jegliches
einfühlungsvermögen dass man kinder und
familien aus schließt aus angeboten dass
man kann sich anders formulieren wir die
kinder ausgrenzen damit erwachsene essen
feiern und ins puff gehen können das
passt genau in das bild dieser wirklich
kinderfeindliche politik die der
berliner rot rot grüne senat in berlin
betreibt das kinderfreundlichste
bundesland man kann es nicht anders
sagen und genau der punkt auch beim
thema ausnahmen du gerade angesprochen
das ist sehr sehr relevanter
kinderschutzbund hat schon angekündigt
heute morgen zu prüfen ob man dagegen
sich auch klagen kann genau aus dem
grund weil es halt familien und
kinderfreundlich ist und möglicherweise
auch dann damit gegen das grundgesetz
verstößt das heißt wenn man als familie
mit kindern unter zwölf in ein
restaurant gehen will weiß man überhaupt
nicht ob man das darf ob die kinder
draußen bleiben müssen oder nicht die
gastronomen dürfen das ja frei
entscheiden welche regeln sie anwenden
sie werden sich natürlich lieber dafür
entscheiden die stühle vollzumachen nach
einer so schwierigen zeit und zu sagen
wir machen jetzt hier alle genesen und
geimpften als darauf setzen na ja
vielleicht kommen die familien nicht so
richtig wissen wie kann das sein dass
nach all dieser zeit in dieser pandemie
die kinder ganz offensiv erneut so
vergessen so ausgegrenzt werden es geht
ja vor allem auch um die kinder über
zwölf also die die sich theoretisch
impfen lassen könnten aber gibt ja auch
gründen dass man sagt man lässt sich
nicht impfen aber diese kinder werden ja
die ganze zeit in den schulen getestet
regelmäßig dreimal die woche von daher
gibt es einen sehr sehr großen schutz ja
ich kann diese frage nur so beantworten
das ist hier das hier einfach komplette
ignoranz herrscht und das möglicherweise
gar nicht klar ist ob wohl auch der ein
oder andere senator in unserem
bundesland ja kinder hat was das
eigentlich für familien bedeutet das ist
diese über griffigkeit des staates die
wir immer und immer wieder sehen und man
hatte ja gedacht mit dem abebben der
pandemie und einem stärkeren im status
einer höheren impfquote würde diese über
griffigkeit des staates abnehmen aber
wir sehen gerade in berlin immer wieder
regeln bei denen wir verstehen müssen
sie sind absurd bestes beispiel eine
kindergartengruppe will auf den
fernsehturm hier in berlin in athen dass
die letzte kindergartengruppe da sind
die fünf und sechsjährigen drin die
fünfjährigen in der gruppe brauchen
keine maske und kein test die
sechsjährigen in der gruppe brauchen
einen test und eine maske wer soll das
bitte noch verstehen
[Musik]